dans les premières phases de l'iran les
faits avait été frappé de voir le nombre
de tweets notamment de personnalités
politiques qui disent je ne suis pas
médecin mais je pense qu'il faut faire
ceci sous là où cela est qu'ils disaient
leur point de vue sur quels traitements
sur quelles mesures préventives sur tel
médicament même sans rien y connaître et
ça ça illustre ayant l'important
aujourd'hui c'est au fil du temps à
force de ressort des informations sur le
petit coronavirus on a compris que la
sphère était diablement compliqué que
quand on parle de test il faut
s'entendre sur six séries de tests
virologiques ou sérologique et c'est une
affaire très compliquée et donc on est
un peu plus prudent dans sa place on
parlait des sapins illustre parfaitement
un biais cognitifs connue depuis très
longtemps mais qui a été baptisé
seulement en 1999 par deux psychologues
américains qui s'appelle downing et
kruger et cp ce fait downing krueger
comme on l'appelle maintenant se résume
en un double paradoxe premier paradoxe
on ne peut savoir qu'on est incompétent
que si on les compétents donc c'est en
acquérant de la compétence qu'on se rend
compte qu'on est incompétent mais au
début on est sûr de soi on découvre un
nom un nouveau champ assez un virus ah
bah c'est comme la grippe le marché ce
qu'il faut faire et puis après on se
remet la somme bois c'était la chanson
de jean gabin vous souvenez de la
chanson légende j'ai peur quand on était
enfant je sais je sais il ya la fin de
sa vie il avait compris qu'on ne sait
jamais il avait la garde et c'était une
formule bizarre parce que je ne suis pas
médecin cela dessus ans que je suis
incompétent et donc c'est honnête
intellectuellement en admet qu on est
incompétent et ensuite on parle comme un
sachant et ça m'avait tellement frappé
que j'ai hérité dirait didier ce tract
est ce que montre l'effet de nine kruger
c'est que après quand on se met à
travailler on se rend compte qu'on est
incompétent donc on perd en assurance et
puis l'assurance que la confiance qu'on
a en soi remonte à mesure qu'on acquiert
des compétences
[Musique]